Vietnamese girls let's game
over total respect total respect if
you're a woman at whatever race you are
I don't care and you think you're fine
there's always a Vietnamese [__] that's
going to
outshine she's there she's like wherever
you walk into some club and you're like
oh my God I'm hot [__] some vietnames
girl walks by you're like what
Angels just go to westmin or or Texas
Houston enem these Americans are
different why are they different we just
got him some heavy racism you just wave
that right off no I'm just saying our
Vietnamese girls in America dude
they that's what he likes oh he loves
that the Vietnamese girls here
Vietnamese but the inside of a Latina
that's everywhere that's Jerry's
[Laughter]
ultimate come on over to Garden Grove